esta es radio canadá internacional
bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
café y una emisión producida por la
sección en español del difusor público
radio canadá internacional difundimos en
directo cada viernes a las dos y cuarto
por las redes sociales en internet en
esta emisión les presentamos destacados
temas de la semana así como el compartir
sus mensajes enviados por correo
electrónico este programa también se
encuentra disponible en nuestro sitio en
internet eres en el punto sea
hoy nos acompañan en los micrófonos
pablo gómez barrios de honor a chapman
leonardo gimeno en la versión radio de
este programa escucharemos la música del
dúo conformado por las hermanas de
toronto lex y valentín y natalia
balearic kings ellas de revistas
mexicanas que este año lanzaron la
versión en español de 6 canciones
originales otro dúo esta vez del mundo
indígena dying roots buscando raíces
compuesto por su acción hachís y
reivindicará taktá traerán el tema ha
llegado la hora de irnos y también
iremos aún más al norte al ártico para
escuchar el tema a nuri inspirado en las
tradiciones del canto de la garganta de
garganta de los inuit y volvemos al pop
canadiense con michelle hold todo esto
en la versión radio de esta emisión bien
pablo leonora leonardo que tal pues
muchas gracias por la bienvenida un
cordial saludo pues a todos los que nos
están escuchando y escucha viendo en
este momento y contento de estar
nuevamente aquí con ustedes
con cuerno durante si puedes poner una
ausencia de tres meses
incapacitado para trabajar porque me
lastimé la mano y bueno entonces el
consuelo que me quedaba era mirar el
facebook live entonces pues todos los
viernes estaba ahí puntualizó viendo el
programa como todos los escucha viendo
el programa como todos nuestros oyentes
o como suelen hacer algunos de nuestros
oyentes y la próxima semana tomás la
ampliación del programa timón en la
rienda del programa así será con un gran
placer bueno vamos a ver cómo andar todo
perfecto pero en ahora entonces
empecemos con lo que te debo la atención
está semana yo creo que eso nos llamó la
atención a todos en canadá pues se
legalizó el consumo recreativo de la
marihuana
entró esto en vigencia o en vigor este
miércoles y se le formaron todas el 17
no sé si se la mamá
todavía suficiente no había suficiente
para toda la gente que quiso comprar a
lo mejor debe haber muchos
por primera vez sienten que se pueden
permitir de fumar
también el programa francés y
efectivamente un montón de gente que no
lo hizo hasta ahora porque el ilegal
claro ahora que puede ir a comprarlo
como si fuera una somos mayores podemos
hacerlo
-18 tuvo muchísima prensa internacional
es el segundo país en el mundo que
legaliza totalmente este tipo de consumo
después de uruguay uruguay fue el
primero pero además es el primer país
dentro del g7 entonces tiene una
connotación bien particular
lo bueno se habló muchísimo esta semana
pablo estuvo comentando del trabajo lo
que hicieron en la marihuana y el
consumo en el trabajo y a mí me llamó la
atención después de esto es que hubo un
canadiense por el primero que sufrió una
multa también porque la policía lo
encontró tomando en el auto y entonces
una multa de casi 700 dólares y yo me
estaba preguntando por por fumar en el
auto lo cual me parece muy bien porque
cuando uno fuma pues a lo mejor pierde
un poquito la noción de la realidad se
vuela y puede volar sin chocar no sé si
matar a otra persona me preguntaba
simplemente si desde winnipeg en
manitoba ocurrió esto si es es la misma
ustedes que conducen autos y es lo mismo
la misma multa para la gente que lo
encuentran bebida con problemas con
alcohol alcoholizada en el volante ahora
que es la misma multa de casi 700
dólares en la misma multa pero pero si
está totalmente prohibido conducir
borracho como en un buen ayudante 52.8
18 puntos 8.5 para aquellos que tienen
en realidad hay un punto 51.8 que para
la mayoría de la gente lo que no me
queda claro es que por ejemplo o sea en
este caso el tipo estaba fumando en su
auto no no sé si va conduciendo y
fumando al mismo tiempo en fin en no ver
la noticia pero lo que no me queda claro
es si está prohibido
fumar mientras estás manejando o si yo
voy manejando y me orilló al lado de la
carretera o de la calle igual salgo del
auto me fumo me bloqueé me quiero fumar
y después me amargo pues no puedes ni
tomando ni fumado pues dice sigamos
puedes llevar tu tu dosis de marihuana
en el auto siempre y cuando esté en el
cofre decías una guantera no son como
los celulares pues claro pero no lo
puedes consumir ni es lo mismo con el
alcohol
el código pasado estaba en toronto y
este es lo que ese estudio acceden
autorruta justo al entrar la ciudad 490
por conducir borracho no está no ni
siquiera borracho extraído traído con el
teléfono será con teléfono con amarilla
con esperando a que prueben distraído
tienes que tener algo que justifique que
esté distraído digo el teléfono entonces
si estás había hecho un artículo sobre
la distracción al volante y escuchar la
radio distrae
dice que lo mejor es ir en silencio y
con una persona que tenga carnet de
conducir al lado porque hay dos personas
están vigilantes en el tema cuando uno
conduce ahora cómo puede darse cuenta si
vos estás escuchando la música ya viene
mejor que los autos vienen con música
con todo eso así que no debería los
puentes de la vía igual está comprobado
de que cuando uno maneja y escucha
música la la atención no está ciento por
ciento puesta en la ruta sino que hay
una especie de dispersión gracias a la
radio y otra cosa también la multa más
grande y más grave creo que se la da a
la persona que le ofrecen marihuana a un
menor de 19 años 19 en todas las
provincias creo que sí sí 9 - en quebec
y en 98 de sector es 18 ahora algo nuevo
gobierno que le llevará 21 por eso ya
está discutir pero por el momento digo
hay otras provincias que donde dicen que
ese 19 para arriba entonces hay una
multa
extremadamente fuerte de miles de
dólares si la policía ve que le estás
ofreciendo marihuana a un joven lo cual
también me parece muy interesante en las
redes sociales estaba viendo en
reacciones en otros países estaba viendo
por ejemplo comentarios de que con esta
ley comenzó la ruina de canadá que
canadá si se viene abajo lo mismo decían
de uruguay finalmente uruguay o portugal
que tiene una política muy interesante
también de permisión de todas las rocas
y holanda y el dinero igual en colorado
que es uno de los únicos en realidad
creo que hay dos estados de eeuu no está
permitido el consumo recreativo
según los estudios un crecimiento del
consumo durante los primeros dos años
después de la normalidad ni siquiera eso
tampoco claro no es que la gente va a
salir a fumar para poder probablemente
aumente porque como decía que leonard
hace un rato o sea la gente está
intrigada por y ahora que según hoy
aprendí que en realidad hay distintos
tipos dentro de lo que se va a vender
entonces tenés para el sedante tipo
sedante tipo calmante
hay varios ejemplos de lo que hacen que
es un vino claro el catar vinos a ciegas
igual tiene que ver mucho con la persona
con la persona que consume si es una
persona primero eso segundo si está
acompañado de otras cosas si tiene la
persona tiene está tomando otras drogas
o consume solamente eso es exactamente
lo mismo no porque sea natale le está
permitido el consumo libre de alcohol
la gente sale como loca emborracharse no
es cierto una cosa es entonces tomar un
vino o fumar en una fiesta y otra cosa
es fumar o tomar un vaso de vino después
de que te anuncian de que tu pareja se
divorcia lo mismo amar que ser amado es
bueno y otro es con respecto encadenando
con el mismo tema está este asunto con
la legalización de fumar en el trabajo
claro ss ss otro problema y hay una hay
un periódico a que estaba escuchando eso
en los medios que un periódico que se
llama el toronto star que es el más
grande periódico de canadá
prohibió envió una nota a todos los
trabajadores siendo muy claro que la
tolerancia es cero y que está totalmente
prohibido la posesión ni si quiera o sea
no estamos hablando de fumar sino la
posesión de marihuana en en el diario en
el edificio quiere decir de que por
ejemplo un viernes en la tarde
a la hora del almuerzo vas a la tienda
de la esquina donde puedes comprar tu
marihuana que la metes en el bolsillo no
tienes la intención de fumar tela porque
estás trabajando y no te gusta fumar
cuando estás en el trabajo entonces te
vienes para llevar tela para el fin de
semana en tu casa pero si te sorprenden
con la marihuana en el bolsillo aunque
no haya fumado pues tienes problemas en
tu trabajo
es como lo mismo con el alcohol si
quieres tomar un vino el sábado y
realmente solo tienes tiempo el viernes
a la salida del trabajo te vas y te
compras el vino y entonces esa es la
idea de que al menos en esta casa
todavía no hemos recibido una noticia no
sabemos por el momento pero podemos
aprender algo acá igual no hemos sentido
el error en las calles todavía porque en
nuestros últimos tres días ha habido
muchísimo viento pero con sonseca en
calme un poquito el viento creo que lo
vamos a sentir en la casa
todo está un poco todas estas políticas
que están implementando me doy cuenta
que están basadas un poco en los mismos
términos que el consumo de alcohol
mezclar origen o el cigarrillo por
ejemplo había una persona que preguntaba
en radio canadá cuando había había un
programa decía es que yo soy locatel soy
alquiló una casa lo que voy a tener
derecho a fumar y dice depende del
propietario es lo autoriza o no es decir
hay propietarios que no quieren que las
personas fumen por ejemplo entonces se
firma eso en el contrato entonces bien
más o menos lo mismo va a ser con la
marihuana es decir tienes que tener la
autorización del propietario si quieres
fumar estipulado en el contrato de
alquiler duro puede poner prohibido
dentro del apartamento si usted quiere
fumar o cigarro o marihuana per salga al
balcón afuera exacto pero adentro
tiene que haber una distancia de nueve
metros eso para los que no lo sé en
lugares públicos y pero los propietarios
también pueden establecer ese criterio y
el gobierno dio un plazo de 60
a 90 días para acomodar para que todos
los propietarios entren en acuerdo con
los inquilinos landrón adac tiquete
llamó atención esta semana antes de lo
que me llamó la atención un saludo de
luis balderas que dice saludos de sant
antoni de chile oyendo atentamente
vuestros temas nunca dice bienvenidos
amigos decana de las américas es café un
saludo cordial para todos y dispuesto a
aprender algo de lo que expongan en el
día de hoy bienvenido gracias conecta
con nosotros y lo conmigo como es la más
que fuma marihuana es la tecnología se
cayó se cayó youtube cuando durante un
par de horas
hoy no el viernes fue hoy viernes con un
error de los servidores a nivel mundial
estuvimos yo es más yo me enteré porque
se rompió mi cafetería buscó en un vídeo
de youtube para ver cómo se arregla y no
anda y se desconecta el internet pues el
internet el teléfono no andaba abría la
computadora ya te pusiste
you tube caído la cantidad de gente
protestando uno llorando se acaba mi
vida porque youtube increíble el traje
durante no sé si fue aproximadamente una
hora o un poco más estuvo caído
el blog se estuvieron caídos los
servidores de youtube a nivel mundial
así que primicia guanábano mía por
supuesto pero primicia para esto que es
la primera vez que tienen este problema
a nivel mundial
a mí lo que me llama la atención es este
esta operación que está siendo llevada a
cabo para para que arabia saudita salga
del paso de la presunta muerte del
periodista llama al casting presunto
asesinato presunto asesinato y como un
ex actor de la cia y actual citar el
estado de eeuu mike pompeo vaya se reúne
con los turcos y trata de iu y pnv y la
mente dice que pase lo que pase que es
adiós este es un gran aliado de eeuu
gran dice que son que son los negocios
más de mayor volumen en toda la historia
de la humanidad y ser siempre
hiperbólico pues pero corriente que
tiene negocios de miles de millones de
dólares con de provisión de armamento a
arabia saudita que justamente con ese
aval está atacando yemen donde están
muriendo tantos miles y millones mis 3
millones de personas que están aquí
están afectadas y entonces toda esta
operación de relaciones públicas a nivel
internacional
y lo y lo concreto es que donald trump
es responsable de alguna manera de ese
si se confirma que ha sido decapitado o
torturado o asesinado en el consulado de
arabia saudita index utilizado desde en
el avión para poder sacar lo que no se
dan cuenta que llevan el cuerpo eso es
lo que entendido que había sido como
triturado es terrible lo que han hecho
con ese periodista ese jamal caijing
a pesar de todo lo que estás diciendo
rufo me sorprende digo es a esa brutal o
necesidad de trump porque no hay muchos
dirigentes que podrían reconocer lo que
le está reconociendo dejando esto de
lado creo y esto muestra un poco lo que
los eeuu es decir se rigen por por los
dólares en su política exterior ahora en
lo que a mí me digo está este asesinato
presunto asesinato contra este
periodista está de todas maneras
perjudicando a arabia saudita la gran
imagen que quiere llevar ante el mundo
con la cuando asumió al nuevo príncipe
el hijo del rey diciendo que éste iba a
cambiarla
política interna de derechos humanos en
arabia saudita se está cayendo a pedazos
esa imagen eso me parece que es un punto
importante y había una reunión anunciada
para fin de mes a una niña a la cual se
le llama 'de habla de el davos del
desierto que reúne a la gente de los
negocios de las finanzas es la crema de
la crema del mundo y que se están
desistiendo uno detrás de otro para
asistir canadá ya dijo que no va a
enviar a nadie
el fondo monetario dijo que no va el
banco mundial y otros grandes grupos
económicos entonces es un golpe para
arabia saudita esto y creo que es la
primera vez que sucede este test esto
que si se cae esa máscara no de ese país
en cuanto a los derechos humanos a las
políticas represivas que tienen y no hay
que olvidarse que canadá rompió
prácticamente no canadá arabia saudita
rompió casi relaciones con canadá porque
de nunca nada había denunciado a la que
cuando es arabia saudita había puesto en
prisión enviado a prisión a dos mujeres
activistas entonces creo
es importante lo que está pasando
lamentablemente que esto se produzca por
el asesinato el supuesto asesinato de un
periodista pues es muy triste y
lamentable y la manera y las
circunstancias en que ocurrió no sí
distintos medios de prensa en canadá
habían señalado justamente que trump
esta actitud de trampas de los medios y
hace los periodistas estaba creando un
clima que hacía impune que creaba un
tema de integral frente a este tipo de
abusos y justamente el periódico the
guardian publicó esta ayer como donald
trump había dio a la voz a uno de sus
conservadores que físicamente atacó a un
periodista de guardián en eeuu
entonces eso justamente momentos en que
se está discutiendo en el suelo del
debate internación sobre la suerte de
este periodista de arabia saudita es
decir que page es la incivilidad es tan
grande que en momentos así él todavía va
a decir ese es el tipo de persona que yo
quiero pero yo sí
así que eso es lo que me llama la
atención esta semana y sobre todo esto
que alguien decía una yemenita la
profesora yemenita decía como la muerte
de esta persona cobra tal importancia
cuando hay millones de afectados en
yemen entonces sobre importancia porque
era una también una personalidad pública
este periodista justamente apareció en
los medios porque se atrevía a denunciar
al régimen de arabia saudita primero y
segundo porque vivían estados unidos
publicaron claro entonces de todas
maneras es importante que se destaque
eso pero lo que me sorprende entre otras
cosas bueno sucedió pero pero asesinatos
de periodistas ocurren en latinoamérica
y en el mundo
en una forma tan brutal como lo han
asesinado a esta persona pero pero hay
barba y es que se cometen no sino tan
sólo en latinoamérica como en otros
lugares del mundo y no tienen la misma
prensa es que es menos común lo que
vivimos ahora
dentro de otro estado
ninguno escucha en méxico mataron de
nuevo a un periodista o pusieron en la
cabeza del periodista en colgado de un
puente y qué bárbaro pero como que
estamos más lamentablemente
acostumbrados a escuchar eso que viene
de méxico de aquel lado no estábamos
acostumbrados no se le daba prensa se ha
pasado nada nadie lo sabía entonces
ahora es como un golpe porque aparte
tiene la connotación de eeuu en el medio
turístico la connotación del petróleo no
hay que olvidarse lo que es arabia
saudita y el petróleo en el mundo y las
armas o sea
europa y eeuu son los principales
vendedores de armas
por eso yo creo que tiene tanta
resonancia además de haber cometido este
hecho dentro de un territorio neutro que
es un consulado no están escuchando
canadá en las américas café y en radio
que en la internacional de música de
recuerdo que escucharemos a dos hermanas
hijas de inmigrantes mexicanos en
toronto
lex y valentín y nadie a valeri kane con
la canción espíritus
un dúo indígena canadiense sesión a que
vengan a tacto con ha llegado la hora de
irnos ajustaremos a la cantante invita a
evaluar cantando el tour y michel the
world esos temas estarán en nuestro
contenido en en nuestro sitio interés
eres el punto sea pasamos ahora a brehme
yo tengo aquí saludos a gente analía
comentarios en este caso césar rodríguez
harry dice saludos desde bogotá se
hablar café de canadá las américas
javier gonzález nungaray dice a ver si
comentan algo respecto a la caravana de
migrantes hondureños por cierto que está
en la frontera de méxico y guatemala
justamente ya hemos hecho una entrevista
con un periodista refugiado en canadá
félix molina quien el de origen
hondureño le pegaron dos tiros y por su
trabajo periodístico justamente y él
señalaba en entrevista que en realidad
son las políticas de eeuu las que son
directamente responsables de esta
situación por haber avalado un golpe de
estado
el presidente mel zelaya zelaya y luego
haber avalado es un fraude electoral con
el urgente presidente entonces bueno en
toda américa latina este este viraje
neoliberal no que le encarna muy bien el
actual presidente de honduras entonces
que no la historia muestra que no ha
servido para satisfacer las demandas las
necesidad de la mayoría de población
entonces es lo que señala esta esta
persona y él dice que es legítimo que
los hondureños y los que son víctimas de
este tipo de políticas tengan que buscar
espacios donde poder buscar condiciones
de vida mínimas mejores no y lo que
decía en un reportaje muy interesante en
the national que es el noticiero de si
bici de radio canadá a la noche hicieron
un reportaje muy interesante señalando
justamente este este fenómeno de los que
hablan de cuatro mil personas que están
en pakistán creo que llegando a la
frontera con mil veces y que ya están en
la frontera
si a este análisis del international
decía que en realidad ese es una
fanfarronada un poco de trump nuevamente
porque se sabe que la gente más que nada
estos migrantes lo que hacen es
manifestar su descontento a la mayoría
de ellos no llegan a eeuu lo que él dice
que está utilizando políticamente esto
trump por las elecciones que vienen
ahora en noviembre de medio término que
le dicen y fíjense que según encuestas
una reciente encuesta llevada a cabo en
eeuu sobre las preocupaciones del 2002
por ejemplo de los la gente que es el
partido demócrata que le preocupa más en
este momento lo primero que salía era el
tema de las acceso a la salud y la
violencia que está causando las armas y
cuando en entrevistaron hay
simpatizantes de republicanos decían
cuál es la principal preocupación los
indocumentados y los inmigrantes
ilegales se entiende entonces toda esta
retórica que está utilizando en este
momento trump porque está dirigiéndose a
esto a este electorado para que vayan a
votar y conseguir de nuevo los votos en
ese sentido me pareció interesante
también el análisis
de civis international no claro
efectivamente porque para terminar lo
que decía me llamó la atención es que
él quiere construir su muro entonces
vuelve con esa retórica también de
construir el muro y acusando américa
aunque se cuida mucho con mexico ahora
pero finalmente en el recientemente
electo presidente lópez obrador frente a
todo este drama de los centroamericanos
ya dijo ayer o antes de ayer que él ya
habló con trump y quiere encontrar
soluciones al tema y que él considera
que méxico puede hacer cosas por los
migrantes centroamericanos y dijo que va
a haber trabajo para los que quieren
quedarse en mexico y todo aquel
centroamericano que quiera trabajar en
mexico va a obtener un permiso de
trabajo inmediatamente entonces a mi ver
se están pasando cosas interesantes en
mexico y que acá no se destaca mucho eso
tampoco
indudablemente es un maestro del
desconcierto
fríamente calculado y lo hago de una
manera tan especial y se toma le toma el
pelo a la prensa le toma el pelo a la
oposición le toma el pelo todo el mundo
y se divierte con estas para mí el tipo
está muerto de la risa se acuerda de esa
frase que dijo
candidato cuando era candidato él dijo
pero me quiere tanto la gente va a
mostrar tanto por mí que yo puedo llegar
a la quinta avenida de nueva york y
pegar un tiro a una persona matar una
persona y la gente va a votar por mí me
hace acordar eso fue lo que dijo
bolsonaro bolsonaro que también hace de
estas declaraciones de esa naturaleza en
escena del tema de méxico yo creo que
tiene muy buenas intenciones andrés
manuel lópez obrador
de ofrecerle a los refugiados
centroamericanos de quedarse médico en
méxico digo si quieren pero lo que yo me
pregunto es que la intención de ellos no
es méxico el objetivo no es méxico es
estados unidos entonces aunque méxico
les proponga quedarse en su territorio
me pregunto si van a querer quedarse y
no van a intentar de cualquier forma que
sea de entrar a eeuu que es el objetivo
no creo que se me recuerda un poco
para ver si es para todos si se puede
generalizar hay mucha gente que sale de
centroamérica por una cuestión de
inseguridad tan grande de violencia que
dentro de todo méxico debe ser un
paraíso para ellos también y 50 es
trabajo aún mejor no en tu lengua está
bien puedes ser parte de lo que dices no
la verdad que no no lo puedo mucho
avanzar sobre ese tema pero no hay
encuestas tampoco son o no hay así de
que bueno veremos no pero me parece pues
como poco como política de andrés manuel
lópez obrador de ofrecer esta
posibilidad a los migrantes pues es
fantástica en claro tiendas y damos
respuesta a nuestro compañero que está
allí en méxico en el méxico en méxico
perfecto damos una breve vuelta por los
miguel rovira que está en montornès de
dónde es que es la
en el pueblo de miguel no me acordé de
este momento ya te lo va a decir el
buenas tardes dice desde barcelona
españa que lo pasé muy bien juntos todos
los componentes del programa canadá en
las américas café y muchos saludos a
todos los oyentes un fuerte abrazo y
muchos 73 muy bien gracias un saludo
viene una breve vuelta a los mensajes de
nuestros oyentes
yo tengo menos inmigrantes en el que
beck del nuevo gobierno es una buena
idea esta es una reportaje y comenta
héctor y dice jota héctor y dice es
obligación hablar el idioma y adaptarse
a nuestras leyes respetando las en sus
hogares e iglesias conserven su cultura
al no hacerlo corren el riesgo de ser
víctimas de abusadores este es el
comentario de jota héctor acá con su
nuevo acuerdo comercial canadá cede su
soberanía a un matón
j héctor dice en idioma inglés se lee un
sms a para mí el nuevo tratado es entre
dos países estados unidos de méxico
canadá a quienes redactaron el documento
ignoran los nombres correctos de los
tres firmantes o soy yo el ignorante
aclaren me por favor
pide que la estación lo y lo interesante
también es si saben ustedes ahora cómo
se están lo llaman en méxico al tratado
y que me parece que se pronuncia mucho
mejor en castellano al dicente make
tratado méxico-estados unidos-canadá que
me suena mejor no se utilizan el sms
pronuncia united states méxico en canadá
pero es impronunciable son para la para
américa latina hay otra opción que era
el imeca
me gusta y me gusta que me ha tratado
méxico-estados unidos-canadá queda mejor
muy bien bien mensajes y aquí tengo otro
mensaje
alexander ascanio bayona dice poner a le
manda un mensaje de solicitud de
información y si tenemos 35 años de edad
nacionalidad colombiana y quiere
información para ingresar a canadá igual
que pedro fabián rodríguez que nos
escribe desde buenos aires así que a
ellos les decimos en los artículos
escritos en radio qhana internacional
están los vínculos para poder ir a
informarse en la página de inmigración
canadá que es donde realmente uno tiene
que hacer el proceso en los últimos
quince minutos del programa que anna de
las américas café pasamos ahora los
temas de la semana y tú
leonora has conversado a propósito del
futuro
latino quebequenses según la cámara de
comercio latinoamericana
en el tema miguel rovira que nos escribe
en montornès del vallès vallès un buen
vino ese nombre
[Risas]
rufo se trató de una entrevista en el
marco de la octava edición de la semana
hispano font a 2018 que se viene
llevando a cabo hace 8 años que sí es
que tiene un lugar aquí en la ciudad de
montreal fue esta semana al igual que
años anteriores hay muchísimas
actividades hay conferencias de mesas
redondas y está organizada por la
escuela de idiomas y el instituto de
estudios internacionales de montreal y
esta vez el tema central que englobaba a
todas las presentaciones era el diálogo
y reconciliación que tiene que ver un
poco con lo que está sucediendo en dos
países en colombia y en
justamente estuvieron los cónsules de
esos dos países hicieron una
presentación en este marco colombia por
haber llevado a cabo un proceso de paz
la firma de la paz y méxico cuyo recién
electo presidente lópez obrador pues
prometió también una comisión de la
verdad una investigación casa que hasta
el momento nunca se hizo en mexico no
solamente hablamos las violaciones de
derechos humanos en fin eso está en
discusión y dentro de eso entreviste a
héctor giraldo que es director general
de la cámara de comercio latinoamericana
que se hizo una presentación junto a
otras personas sobre el futuro de los
latinos quebequenses entonces le
pregunté un poco que tenía que ver esa
presentación de el futuro de latinos
quebequenses con el tema de diálogo y
reconciliación y me dio una explicación
bien interesante en parte porque él dice
que las familias que llegan de américa
latina' muchas de ellas llegan aquí
habiendo sufrido persecución en estos
países habiendo sufrido conflictos
violencia entonces esto se inscribe aquí
en un tema de reconciliación dice eso
dice el que permite que las personas
puedan pues dialogar también sobre eso
lo que les pasó en sus países de
orígenes e intentar pues una nueva vida
acá también se refiere al hecho de que
los inmigrantes que están acá y que
sufren
una cierta forma de podríamos decir de
prever prejuicios ya sea por la piel por
en fin por por lo que sea los
latinoamericanos él dice que sufren por
ejemplo esto se verifica en la falta de
trabajo o que tienen títulos
universitarios que no les reconocen y
que también es motivo de discriminación
acá pues también se inscribe eso dentro
de este de este tema de reconciliación
de diálogo y en ese sentido la cámara de
comercio- latinoamericana pues está
aportando su grano de arena para que
ésta estos inmigrantes que llegan acá
pues vivan otro tipo de vida
-pablo justamente en el marco de esta
semana hispanófono aquí en montreal
bogotá así es en el marco de esta semana
hispana la octava edición de la semana
hispana que es organizada por la
universidad de quebec en montreal está
también el tema de la movilidad
internacional dentro de las mesas
redondas que se organizan
en el marco de la semana hispana y la
movilidad internacional está en la
escuela de verano 2019 que es un
proyecto que presentó una profesora la
profesora jessica falleras de la ucam
presentó este proyecto en el que la idea
es digamos aprovechando está este
contexto ahora que en colombia se firmó
la paz y que aparentemente es un país
menos peligroso que lo que fue antes
cuando era la guerra y entonces pues
ella presentó en colaboración con la
universidad javeriana de bogotá este
proyecto a la ucam y la idea es pasar
desde son proyectos dos modalidades si
tú quieres una de dos semanas y otra de
tres semanas para participar en la
escuela de verano
salen del 29 de abril al 10 de mayo o
del 29 de abril al 17 de mayo están dos
o tres semanas en bogotá y tienen cursos
de español avanzado ser ese es
organizado también por la escuela de
lenguas de la universidad de quebec aquí
en montreal y bueno pues es una
conversación interesante sobre cómo
funciona esta escuela de verano y porque
igual y cómo van a navegar la cuestión
de los los acentos la sentó paisa en que
hacen todo está muy clarito no el acento
en colombia es muy clarito ese es más el
acento bogotano que es el que en
realidad que es donde se dice que se
tiene el mejor acento el español mejor
hablado 10-0 de bogotá hay hasta ahí nos
está escuchando nuestro amigo césar
augusto rodríguez jarr y que es de
bogotá entonces se dice que es en bogotá
donde se habla el mejor español
en hispanoamérica los costarricenses
dicen lo mismo
cuando yo iba al hotel ramada herradura
que hay que acostumbrarse a la errática
vida para todos los ticos del norte de
la argentina claro pero me pero no es
tanto en costa rica es bastante más
pronunciada es un sonido encima más
cerrado lo que interesante en canadá es
justamente como cuando conoces
canadienses que están abriendo aprendan
en español
quién fue el profesor provincia o si son
amigos con quien aprendieron mi hija por
por ejemplo habla español y estuvo
viviendo en chile cierto tiempo sí bueno
[Música]
gracias al bien de unos hablas de una
muerte anunciada en el mundo de la
tecnología así es se murió
google+ se murió
en realidad dentro de 10 meses lo único
va a quedar solamente funcional para
aquellos que trabajan con la cv con la
suite de google
la suite de google de empresas está bien
son los únicos que van a poder ingresar
concretamente la plataforma de la red
social no nos afecta a nosotros en nada
porque yo tenía una cuenta creo que
entre dos veces en un año o sea ese era
el problema también pero lo más
interesante este tema es que no es que
muera porque ya estaba decidido en
realidad lo estaba planificado o sea
veía que iba a pasar sino porque saltó
después de un de una investigación del
wall street journal que había una brecha
de seguridad y era a través de google+ y
efectivamente el wall street' encontró
una publicación interna le pasaron
evidentemente una publicación interna de
google que decía que google había
determinado no hacerlo público para
evitar todo el proceso que tuvieron que
hacer por ejemplo los de facebook con el
tema de cambridge analizarán a rendir
cuentas para no rendir cuentas y para no
pasar por todo ese proceso enorme de
citas y de declaraciones investigaciones
y tal y la pedida
además de valor en la bolsa seguramente
está perdido en realidad dos puntos
google después de que cerraran google+ y
que se enterarán de que esto pasó
entonces le cortaron por lo sano o la
brecha fue google+ le cortamos la cabeza
google+
no tiene nada que ver lo que tiene en
cuenta con gmail
no tiene nada que ver igual google en él
la constancia de que esto había pasado
en el papel donde explican qué fue lo
que pasó
dicen que han hecho una investigación y
que no encontraron que ningún dato de
esas aproximadamente 500 mil personas
hubiera sido utilizado para hacer algo
fraudulento qué pasó con los cambios a
analítica la norma incluye exacto en
este caso no había sido utilizado en la
brecha estaba abierta y 438 aplicaciones
podían retirar y conseguir datos a
través de esa brecha pero que no ha
pasado nada a partir de esto como se
reconoció y se probó en el tema de
cambridge hermanos dicen ellos no por
algo se muere
para mí la historia es que se muere para
evitar mayores problemas
no tener que pasar frente al senado eeuu
dando explicaciones y todo esto sea un
mapa yo entonces dijo bueno este fue el
problema listo de los cerramos y así
está celosamente en que quedó facebook
que dio explicaciones ante el congreso y
probó cómo quedó eso provocó una oleada
de todas las aplicaciones plataformas
mandaron
el consentimiento que uno entre comillas
acepta cuando instala una aplicación
ahora es mucho más detallado las letras
chicas son más detalladas digamos eso es
básicamente y que nadie las leyes claros
y la otra cosa es que los
desarrolladores de aplicaciones terceras
digamos que utilizan los los datos de
facebook no pueden usar más bajo
constancia de que si el usuario le dice
que sí entonces sí sino facebook
permitido que la utilización de datos
por empresa y todo eso no eso no fue
castigado multas
no multa no pero lo hicieron transpirar
un poquito y justamente los grupos y
hubo mucha gente en realidad la multa la
hizo la gente porque hubo mucha gente
que dejó la plataforma de facebook
inmediatamente después de los analíticos
pablo sí bueno tenemos acá dos
respuestas a dos preguntas que hicimos
me miguel rovira de montornès del vallès
dice pablo como no claro que hay buen
vino por acá ya lo sospechábamos y se
está rodríguez jarr y dice sin si se
dice que es el mejor español hablando
del español hablado en bogotá no pero
dice pero y el de costa rica es muy
parecido al acento bogotá pero yo lo
identificó a mí me encanta el hermano el
acento costarricense me encanta me
parece fascinante pero me gusta mucho el
colombiano me gusta más el país
me encanta el país
[Risas]
era justamente el rival quería ser la
arribada a face facebook y twitter
cuando apareció en realidad y ahora
facebook se está curando en salud porque
hace pocos días atrás anunciaron que
había anulado cientos y cientos de
cuentas justamente en previsión de las
próximas elecciones en eeuu y eran
muchos sitios políticos sobre temas
políticos muy críticos algunos muy
legítimos como
a new media etcétera entonces todo cuál
es tu presentación pues en la noche del
16 me fui a un lugar cerca de donde
venden mucha marihuana ilegal y fui a un
club a ver qué pasaba se me de noche
entonces estuvieron había músicos que
cantaban el cantaban hip hop y rap y
carla romano de la marihuana que entraba
y salía sino como dije es muy
instrumento con ese lado yo soy de la
línea de lo que tienen que dijo que él
no prueban iba a probar ni le interesa
pero en ese contexto donde tú está donde
se ha formado la segunda fase un
porrista de segunda deportista del
segundo que vale la pena para ver es
como reclama la gente y los músicos muy
contentos porque decían que iban a
finalmente van a poder ir eeuu cree en
ellos
hay que ver eso y que sobre todo no van
a ser perseguidos ni van a tener en
canadá ni van a tener problemas con la
ley ni van a tener antes de estrenar las
entonces estado muy contentos y fumando
su yerba como llegó la manga así pareció
la noche de año nuevo porque llegó la
medianoche y
al frente fue una persona que escuche en
un reportaje que decía yo voy a seguir
con mi putter como con el tipo que
siempre me vendió es amigo mío como lo
voy a alargar después bueno nosotros
tenemos ya y hasta el próximo